Imaginez que vous passiez sept ans au MIT et dans des laboratoires de recherche
pour découvrir seulement que vous êtes un artiste de scène.
(Rires)
Je suis aussi un ingénieur logiciel
et je fabrique toute sorte de créations artistiques avec l'ordinateur.
Et je pense que ce qui m'intéresse le plus
est d'essayer de trouver un moyen de
transformer l'ordinateur en un mode d'expression personnel.
Et beaucoup d'entre vous ici sont les dirigeants de Macromedia et de Microsoft,
et d'une façon, ce sont mes fléaux.
Je pense qu'il y a une grande force d'homogénéisation
que les logiciels imposent aux gens et qui limite leur façon de penser
ce qui est possible sur ordinateur.
Bien sûr, c'est aussi une grande force libératrice qui rend possible,
vous savez, l'édition, les standards, et ainsi de suite.
Mais, d'une façon, l'ordinateur rend possible bien plus
que ce que la plupart des gens pensent, et mon art consiste simplement à
essayer de trouver ma propre façon d'utiliser l'ordinateur,
et donc j'ai fini par écrire des logiciels pour faire ça.
Chris m'a demandé de faire une petite démonstration,
donc je vais prendre tout ce temps -- dix minutes peut-être --
pour faire ça et, si possible, prendre un instant à la fin
pour vous montrer quelques-uns de mes autres projets sous forme de vidéos.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Il nous reste environ une minute.
Je voudrais juste montrer un clip d'un projet plus récent.
J'ai fait une représentation avec deux chanteurs
spécialisés dans la fabrication de bruits étranges avec leur bouche.
Ca s'est passé au mois de Septembre dernier à ARS Electronica
et nous l'avons refait en Angleterre.
Et l'idée est de visualiser leur parole et leur chanson derrière eux
sur un grand écran.
Nous avons utilisé un système de vision par ordinateur
pour suivre leurs déplacements.
Et comme nous savons où sont leur tête,
et qu'ils portent un micro sans-fil
depuis lequel nous traitons le son,
nous pouvons créer des visualisations
qui sont liées très étroitement à ce qu'ils font de leur parole.
Cela va prendre 30 secondes environ.
Il fait un son comme s'il faisait vibrer ses joues.
Bien, il va sans dire que tout n'est pas comme ça, mais ça en fait partie.
Merci beaucoup. Il y a toujours bien plus de choses.
J'ai dépassé le temps prévu, donc je veux juste dire que si vous êtes à New York
vous pouvez voir mon travail à la biennale de Whitney Museum la semaine prochaine,
et aussi à la Bitforms Gallery à Chelsea.
Et maintenant, je crois que je devrais libérer la scène.
Merci beaucoup.